und dann kommt der moment in dem er
endlich cola über den schuh schüttet und
seine reaktion darauf ist manche würden
sagen vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben flüssigkeit schließt aus
einer offenen flasche heraus über die
flaschen öffnung nach unten dreht der
hubert kipp willkommen zu einem neuen
video liebe leute ich bin gerade mitten
in der klausurphase deswegen kommt auch
gerade nur jeden zweiten tag ein video
bis zum 31 wenn ich in der klausurphase
das sind wahrscheinlich über die letzten
klausuren meines studiums
dementsprechend wenig gerät nicht gehabt
die endlich hinter mich zu bringen aber
es wird mal wieder zeit für ein video
der vater aufgefallen und zwar ist mit
pablo rückfällig geworden er hat mir
selbst damals in dem brief mit justin
gesagt dass er versucht hat sein konto
zu verändern und das ganz gut gelungen
über lange zeit aber jetzt hat hier
einfach wieder erwischt dieses dieses
gewisse gehen dieses medium pablo gehen
ihr werdet sie was ich meine rechte
wieder sehen bevor wir loslegen und noch
eine sache sagen miguel bietet wie ihr
wahrscheinlich ich habe nichts
persönlich gegen dich aber dieses video
habe ich einfach ein bisschen getriggert
deswegen das video mit einer prise humor
und fußball im allgemeinen worum geht es
in diesem video mega tabler sitzt
irgendwie einer schönen hotel triton
hatte jedes gekauft aber nicht nur
normal größen sondern auch baby die sie
von was denkt man sich natürlich wenn
man die kleine niedliche turnschuh art
in weiß im schönen wirklich klaren bei
was ist dann der erste gedanke den
vernünftiger mensch hat man schüttet
natürlich cola drüber worden oder es
brauche diese babys und machte ein video
damit aber was könnte ich damit machen
und dann kann die idee kam die idee dass
die fucking cola drüber schritt ist soll
man dazu sagen 1980 hat man darüber nach
gehabt wenn wir seinen 37 jahren werden
autos fliegen
endlos energie geben auf der welt werden
wir krebs geheilt haben liebe leute von
damals ich komme aus dem jahr 2017 muss
sagen die autos fliegen jetzt noch nicht
endlos energie haben jetzt auch noch
nicht aber wir haben typen der cola
überschüttet was auch auffällt leute
mega pablo hat im hintergrund seiner
lieder voller musik an der er garantiert
keine rechte hat und das hat nicht so
wie es die meisten youtube machen also
wie eine kleine anwendung von psycho
andreas oder sowas dann halt die ganze
zeit im hintergrund und zum beispiel
hier shape of jugend gedacht was könnte
man diesen die so machen anja huber hat
also kurz gesagt hat vor diesen schuh
der stunde nicht ganz günstig war in
einem video zu zerstören und war werden
die leute die da heißen einen baum wie
auch cora video verschiedene soßen und
getränke auch diesen schub beim regieren
ok irgendein imprägnierspray muss man an
dieser stelle vielleicht noch bisschen
anders formulieren denn der allererste
link in der beschreibung ist ein amazon
häftling zu diesem trick - bringen
anderen häftlings sind für die von euch
die es nicht kennen aus dem
partnerprogramm mit amazon das heißt
partner an krieg dann so ein link und
wenn deutlich auf den link klicken und
innerhalb von einem zeitfenster von 24
stunden was auf anderen kaufen kriegt
man eine provision für den kauf dass es
selbstverständlich werbung muss als
solche gekennzeichnet werden das macht
wieder pablo auch normalerweise mit den
meisten links da oben bei dem spray bei
diesem zufälligen spray was der erste
linke der beschreibung ist ist irgendwie
keine kennzeichnung wenn man jetzt ganz
böse wäre könnte man dafür
wahrscheinlich abmahnen lassen aber es
braucht dann als nächstes dinge auf die
man über so ein shooter über kippen
könnte um den so renken zu zerstören und
er freut sich lukas dabei und kennt ihr
diese coolen videos auf dieser tour
abreisen jegliche saucen cola fanta
sprite der gesichtsausdruck man raus
fällt auf breiter flur kippen kann aber
auch der moment in dem man merkt das ist
vielleicht nicht so die allerbeste idee
ist neben der zerstörung von diesem
kleinen paar schuhe zeichnet sich das
video aber noch nicht was anderes aus
und zwar durch affen geräusche
[Musik]
als nächstes der löcher ins budget teuer
dieser schuh war bin so aufgeregt
also ich will mich nicht zu weit aus dem
fenster lehnen aber ich glaube das hatte
ich noch nicht gerechnet oder das video
hat jetzt 170000 aufrufe selbst wenn auf
diesem video mit lob hat er mit diesem
video jetzt gerade vielleicht 200 euro
verdient wenn man da noch überlegt dass
ein cola fanta red bull und wein
wahrscheinlich aus der minibar genommen
hat und die saucen waldorf astoria
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal zehn euro
kosten geht das ganze wahrscheinlich
nicht so wirklich auf und dann kommt der
moment in dem er endlich cola über den
schüttet und seine reaktion darauf ist
manche würden sagen vielleicht ein
bisschen übertrieben und geschauspielert
[Musik]
es gibt die schwerkraft flüssigkeit
fließt aus einer offenen flasche heraus
über die flaschen öffnung nach unten
dreht wird nochmals wertet das kann ich
jetzt gar nicht glauben
wer hätte das gedacht leute aber dass
man nicht genug leute denn dieser große
geist unserer zeit dieser forscher auf
der suche nach dem feuer der erkenntnis
begnügt sich nicht damit dass kohle
aufgelaufene flasche fließt die nächste
frage ist natürlich blieb auch fand auch
eine offene flasche das hatte auch
probiert und seine reaktion darauf ist
natürlich selbstverständlich wieder sehr
nachvollziehbar
es ist faszinierend leute wer hätte das
gedacht nicht nur kohle erfolgt der
schwerkraft sondern auch fanta erfolg
der schwerkraft und fließt aus der
offenen klasse
da kann man durchaus auch schon mal nur
ablassen im anschluss daran gibt - aber
noch tolle tipps immer mit dem video
interagieren kann erleichtert wir dass
ich den gekillt wird wie ihre schwerlich
den moralapostel spielen so main konnten
es selbst nicht vollkommen fehlerfrei
aber 150 euro sind viele menschen in
deutschland doch eine ganze menge an
geld und dementsprechend ist vielleicht
nicht ganz cool video auf www kommentar
wer dieses video beziehung gesehen habt
schreibt alle hashtag lang lebe medium
pablo in die kommentare und leute wird
mittlerweile von bei 45 minuten der
overtime so ich habe einfach auf 20.000
dinge zu sagen ich muss sagen wer karten
für einfach mal was haben wir heute
gelernt heute wenn er möglichst wieder
dislike haben wollt dann macht möglichst
lauten geräuschen eurem video benutzt
möglichst auf die b anwendung also
mindestens 20 mal probieren natürlich
die absolut bahnbrechende erkenntnis
leute flüssigkeiten fließen aus der
öffnung von offenen flaschen hinaus
demonstriert auch mal für euch okay weil
ihr euch für die kommentare ob ich im
nächsten video vielleicht cola fanta und
ketchup auf dieses polo packen selbst
gefahren natürlich oben zufällig
natürlich abstecken und meinen kanal
abonnieren und hier oben die neueste
folge von wasser geht um ein format mit
und mediatheken und last weil extra und
selbstverständlich leute auch und zeit
zu zeit und bis zum nächsten mal